I'm the founder of a company called
modal we provide data infrastructure in
the cloud
and I'm going to talk about a very deep
Rabbit Hole I went down where I started
wanting to build a better
set of tools for data engineers and data
scientists and then realized I had to do
a lot of infrastructure to to get there
but but real quick and Taylor already
talked about who I am
I've been working on Moto labs for about
two years
I been working with data for most of my
career in particular I built a music
recommendation system in Spotify open
source thing called Luigi which no one
uses today but at some point was
widely used uh it's a workflow scheduler
I also built a thing called annoy which
is a vector database
which also no one uses today but used to
be someone widely used I have a Blog I
tweet sometimes I was a CTO for many
years also
yeah that's it so so let's talk about
this
deep wrap I this talk is it's like kind
of like two parts I'm gonna get very
technical in like a little bit but I
wanted to contextualize it and like kind
of have a preamble and like talk about
why because technology
is it means to an end like there's no
point building Tech if you don't have a
goal and so um well there's the other
point is it's actually fun so it's fun
to build Tech in my opinion but but
let's be rationalize it so I I started
thinking about better tools for data
Engineers a couple years ago and and and
almost like selfishly wanting to build a
better tool for myself like you know
having worked with data for so many
years like I wanted to build something
that makes me happy when I write code
and when I you know productionize stuff
when I schedule things out when I use
gpus and I'm you know after banging my
head against like AWS docs for 15 years
I figured like maybe we can build better
obstructions
so
I don't think there's like a great way
to quantify
productivity and like how do you measure
it like you can like glance the code
whatever it's a good thing but when I
think about developer productivity I
think the best sort of way to understand
it is to think about uh the the the sort
of the pseudocode of writing code it's
like this like nested set of for Loops
like what is the workflow like you have
this like almost like a nested set of
for loops
sorry if this is like philosophical I'll
get to the technical I promise like 10
minutes but I think this is important so
like you have this like innermost Loop
where you're like writing code and then
you're like run it and you get a syntax
error and you fix it or whatever or like
maybe unit test fails but like the
innermost Loop you were talking like
seconds if you know the the feedback
it's like seconds uh slightly bigger
Loop would be like something like a unit
test or running the script locally or
something like that and it fails in some
way and then you fix it so that's like
minutes
then you like you know you're like done
with a set of commits you push it to
GitHub to create a pull request or
something like that you have to wait for
a co-worker to look at it or cicd to run
or something like that now it's like
hours
and then you're like merch it and you
deploy it to production
and now it's like I don't know days
right let's say you're like building a
chrome job you're like this is going to
be a world's greatest Crown job it's
going to run at midnight and you ship it
and and you're like sitting around
you're like it's midnight and it doesn't
run
this is like something I think most
people have experienced at some point
because you like forgot to send my colon
into yaml or something like that so so
now you have to go back and like add
that semicolon to Play It Again wait
until next midnight so this is kind of
just an example of like you have this
like super long feedback loop nothing
happens uh and
you know that that sort of to me
ruins the joy of writing code
it's not the fun we have to wait and I
think it's good to like contrast this
with with other types of software
Engineers I was a CTO for many as I
looked at other you know software
Engineers people looked at I feel like
almost like people look down on like
front Engineers I don't know why because
like front Engineers they kind of
figured it out like they have amazing
tools so fast like they put like code on
one monitor they put like the the
website on another and then they like
write the code and it like hot reloads
and they get this like super fast like
feedback loop it's almost like this
immediate gratification right there's
something very gratifying about doing
front end if you haven't tried you
should it's actually a lot of fun back
end
sorry about this like image this is like
my placeholder image I put back-end
engineer into stable diffusion this is
what I got
um it's like red code you like does it
compile
you know it doesn't pass you I actually
wonder if like a lot of backend
Insurance are very much into like
compiler or like they like strongly
typed languages and my theory is like
it's actually less about the quality
like the the guarantees it's more about
the feedback loops you get this like
okay like the rust compiler telling you
you have to fix this thing so you have
this like it's kind of nice uh they have
unit tests often so that's nice you can
hear it with that and then they ship it
but then you look at like data teams and
like I don't know what your experience
is writing data start like building data
apps like my experience is like
it's pretty frustrating because you have
this like Crown jobs that take you
talked about Crown jobs but also like
training models or like scaling things
out
you know if you're running things in a
lot of data you have to wait
I'm old I used to use Hadoop a lot you
know growing up
uh you know 10 15 years ago maybe not
yeah 15 years ago
um which is like you know it really
don't you know wish my kids have to use
something like this it would take like
super like you have to write like a
mapreduce job like luckily we did it in
Python at Spotify but we have to sit
around like wait for like an hour for
for your like simple query to run today
there's like data warehouses so I think
there's much better way you get this
like feedback loops but
I think it's sort of in a way actually I
think this has gotten worse in the like
last five years
with the feedback loops because we
started using containers we started
using a bunch of stuff and it got a
little bit worse so okay I'm almost done
with the like philosophical stuff and
then we'll talk about tech
I think a lot of the problem with these
fit you know this like how to compress
the feedback loops is about taking
concerns from the outermost loops and
putting back in the innermost loops and
in particular one of the biggest concern
I have one of the biggest issue I have
is that the infrastructure happens in
the outermost Loop and a lot of stuff
is bad with uh with with with these
feedback loops because things break in
the outermost Thing Once you deployed it
in ways that it didn't break locally and
because these outermost Loops are slow
it's like slow it takes time to push
code to the cloud like people start to
like write code locally instead and
they're like oh I'm just going to run
this thing I'm going to ignore all the
docker containers like whatever I'm just
going to run this thing but then you
make it probably even worse because you
like you know create like a Divergence
in environments
uh which means like you create this like
separation of the environments which
means you introduce like new differences
okay so let's talk a little bit more
about technology what are containers and
containers
I think are my mental model of the
container is basically that it is a
Linux root file system so like if you
open a container
if you look inside of it it basically
has like slash user slash Etc slash lib
like all these things that a Linux
computer has like a VM or or physical
computer this is a lot of stuff too
there's um
some security stuff the resource
isolation but this is kind of like
conceptually what a container does you
can actually do this like you can like
sort of drill a hole at the container
and like you know use it and and I'll
talk a lot about Docker but Docker is
like arguably just one implementation of
like a standard LCI container spec
uh I'll get back to it in a second so
here's like one example we pull this
contain this is python it's like a
standard python used Debian Slim
and some Docker Hub and you pull that
and you you open the container like if
you you can run this command like Docker
save sorry Docker export it's doctor
safe too doctor is very confusing CLI it
always makes them up stalker save works
on images but get the layers it's very
annoying so Docker export on a container
you get basically this tarball and if
you extract that you have this like
whole root file system on disk right and
that's kind of how Docker sort of works
right like Docker one of the
foundational Primitives is this syscall
in Linux called CH root and see it's
root basically if you have a Linux
machine and then you have a root file
system on some directory inside this
Linux machine like you have like a you
know like a root false system inside the
root file system you can point it to
this like
you know the one inside and say actually
run an operating system from here like
here's like a distribution and run it
from here so CH root is like one
primitive and then there's a bit of
other stuff there's some c groups and
some other stuff
um
okay so that was like you know so let's
take it back like what do we actually
want to accomplish here so what I
started thinking about is like
what if we can like retain the the loop
like you know writing code locally but
but instead of running things locally
what if you can actually put it in a
container and launch it in the cloud so
I want to take code locally I want to
spin up a container in the cloud and I
want to run that inside an arbitrary
container and I want to do that
so fast that if
it kind of feels like you know almost
like local development maybe even better
than local development right
uh and so
sort of you know and so so we have all
these like workers in the cloud we have
a thousand machines you know end
machines in the cloud
and we want to support an Arbiter
container to launch in the cloud
uh and we want to do that in about a
second and we want to put code in it too
so
um does this work
it doesn't work there's a video here it
doesn't work it's okay
you can imagine I'm sure you've seen the
screen it's like some progress bar you
pull down a Docker image
takes like a minute maybe sometimes 10
seconds sometimes a minute it depends on
how big it is like Docker images are
like often pretty large especially if
you know standard Locker images like
maybe gigabyte like a Linux distribution
there's like Slimmer months at 100
megabytes but once you start putting in
like Cuda you start putting in torch
like whatever tensorflow I don't know
they they balloon off into like 10
gigabytes so pulling down a Docker image
on a remote host
can take like a minute or two right or
more which is kind of absurd in a way
actually because there's nowhere near
like saturating the network like 10
gigabyte today in AWS like interconnect
should be like a couple of seconds so I
don't know what Docker is doing but it's
not you know very fast
um how do we optimize this if we want to
take code locally and run it in a
container in the cloud we want to do
that with the second latency
uh one observation is that if pulling
down an image is slow can we optimize
this okay so a lot of containers have a
lot of crap in them right like you you
start looking into this container
you see you know this is a fairly small
containers one only not even a gigabyte
but like you know there's a lot of like
time zone information time zone for like
places that you know you're never going
to use there's like time zone for like
uninhabited islands Uzbekistan your app
is never going to like need those right
those are not very large it may be
kilobyte each but it's like you add it
up
you know like you're not going to need
all these files and so a lot of the
stuff in this container is never
actually going to be red like never
and so one thought is like we can
optimize these images right and that's
been like sort of one way people go
about to solving this problem is like
let's just like you know remove all the
stuff you know build this like super
weird like Docker file that like
optimizes I think that's like kind of a
waste of time in my opinion because I
think there's better ways to do it
um
and I think the better ways to do it
sounds skin drinks water is to observe
what actually happens when you start a
container
so so let's you know so what happens
with focusing on python right now
because python is like most commonly
used uh programming language for data
teams
sorry instead of drinking some water
I've been talking to so many people in
my voice is like
it's gonna get like progressively like
uh raspberry
um what happens when you start a
container is the python interpreter is
going to start and then you can import a
bunch of python packages so here's your
second learn is a good example
there's a popular machine learning
library and and package in Python when
you import Pi um scikit-learn it reads
about a thousand files so so and it also
does about 3 000 system calls to stat
the stat is like a system call to to to
get the file information from a file
so it's good and bad news good news is
like this is a lot of system calls this
is a lot of file operations but the good
news is that we're only actually
accessing about a thousand files
actually even slightly less because some
of these are like duplicates so that's
only three percent of the files in this
image and and by uh by by size of the
file I think it's even less
um and and uh you know the first files
this can access is going to be like the
python interpret itself then it's going
to be a shared object files like a bunch
of libraries and then it's going to read
like something like 800 python modules
you know python modules that also like
the pi files but then it does the stats
to check if the pi C file is there
because it's a pre-compiled
um a python module because python does
that
so it does there's a little bit of
redundancy too
okay so so let's you know docker
feels like not the right tool at this
point like for running containers fast
like we want to boot containers pretty
fast in you know let's you know kind of
rehab rehash what I want to do I want to
take code that exists on a local
computer my laptop I'm going to spin up
an arbitrary container in the cloud out
of a pool of n workers
and uh and then run that container right
and and Docker is too slow so uh for
because it takes too much time to pull
down the image
okay so
there is a small little component of
Docker called run C
run C is
um is used by Docker but it doesn't
contain all this like
stuff to pull and push images it doesn't
contain the demon all it does is like
you point it to a root file system you
also give it a Json configuration it has
Network stuff but that's not important
for this and then it runs the container
so that's kind of nice so you can like
basically put a root file system on your
laptop you can say run run C please
start a container from here and then it
starts a container and that's all it
does and then you can kill it at some
point later
uh so here's like a very janky sort of
Rube Goldberg like first version of what
I built
uh to to prove that you can start
containers quickly over the network is
what if we take all these images and we
put them on NFS which is a network file
system
and then I basically tell run C please
start a container from this image over
here that's like a full like unpacked
like root file system like has the user
need to see you know all these like
things uh and run C of obviously it
doesn't know whether it's like a local
or remote file system it doesn't matter
all it needs is the file system so it'll
happily do that
and um
and run the container and so this means
we don't have to wait to pull down the
image right it's suddenly very fast to
start to pull down the image however
starting a container is not very slow
and why is that it's because you know
you saw this s Trace thing uh with with
import SK learn
python does a lot of operations
sequentially it reads like a thousand
python modules like one by one
uh and and NFS latency is a few
milliseconds so if you're doing
you know 4 000 file operations in each
file operations is two milliseconds how
many seconds is that does anyone know
eight seconds very good
multiplying numbers
uh so eight seconds is kind of slow
it's better I mean it's like not
terrible it's faster than most stuff but
I still feel like it like
it's not good it's like it doesn't spark
Joy it's like you launch a container you
want to feel much faster
so NFS latency doesn't feel good enough
and you can use EBS it's a bit faster
uh uh and uh but what what really makes
a difference is like what if you can
cache stuff locally on the worker that's
executing executing these containers
because local SSD latency is known to
order for 100 microseconds it's not
something it's like a much nicer thing
and of course the Linux page cache is
even better so
now we're talking like a couple
microseconds Okay so
caching is good for two reasons
and the two reasons is like one of the
reason is like if we're reading the same
image over and over and we're caching
the files
then the second time we launched the
same image we can launch that image much
faster
but as it turns out a lot of images have
a lot of overlap in the files that they
contain
and so there's an example I just took
like three large images from Docker Hub
and just kind of look at the
intersection did a Venn diagram
and uh as it turns out like even
unrelated images have zero you know
these images have zero layers in common
uh Docker has this like optimization
that caches layers but these these
images have zero layers in common but
even even without layers in common most
of the files are common or most of the
files that we read in at least
so as it turns out like even caching you
know
unrelated images you get a nice
performance boost because you can you
can get very high cash efficiency even
if people are running like arbitrary
custom images with zero layers in common
if we can cache the files caching the
files
it gets a little bit more complex now
caching the files in order to do that
we're going to use like a a an old trick
I think you know this trick has been
many people come up with this because
it's kind of an obvious once you think
about it back in you know starting with
the 60s in the 60s and 70s I think
people came up with this we're going to
do something that's called content
addressing so content addressing means
you hash every file
by its con like you hash the content
and then they use the content the hash
as a location of that file right and the
nice thing about this is that we only
have to store every single file once
even though one file is on like a
thousand images we only have to store it
once so that's really nice from a
storage point of view the second reason
why it's nice is from a caching point of
view if you know the same file is
accessed even like you know they might
show up in different location in
different images
uh we can cache it the second time so so
that's one way to get low latency when
you're reading files
uh and so
we ended up doing this by building a
simple file system Infuse
and here's the secret people think
building file systems is hard
it's not that hard so you can do this
even in Python you can actually build a
file system and we did this in the first
version of this we built a very janky
proof of concept in Python that
basically exposes a file system to run C
but it's not like you know
physical file system what it does under
the hood is it goes over the network and
it fetches files by these like
uh the the hashes that we computed in
advance and I'll get back to how we
compute them in advance and then we
cache them locally on the local SSD
even in Python this actually turns out
to be faster than doing it the whole
thing you know putting everything on NFS
uh but we ended up rewriting it in Rust
uh because which is a much better
language for this anyway
and much faster
I mean like this file system in
particular
I think I forgot maybe one or two here I
think stats should be here but fuse fuse
has like I think 40 different things you
have to implement but that's like
supporting
a rideable thought system in this case
is read only
we use overlay FS on top of that to make
it writable but then but we only have to
support a read-only file system which
means like we only have to implement
like five or six methods some actually
actually makes it a lot easier
and then what do we do in this file
system
this file system basically keeps an
index in memory
of the layout of the of the the the disk
the the root file system
and for every you know for every
location it contains two things it
contains the hash which defines the the
location of this of this uh the content
and a stat struct okay so stat it's like
an old you know Linux thing that
basically contains like the permission
bits whether it's an executable and a
few other things
uh and and you know which is only like I
don't know 20 bytes or something like
that very interesting
okay
so
now rancy wants to read a file you
basically do this we look up in the
index let's say run scene wants to read
whatever the python interpreter so that
is under like user bin whatever python
user bin python I think depends on the
distribution
um we then look up in this in-memory map
where like user bin python has this hash
and we go on C on local SSD do we have
that in disk if that's the case then we
just return it we get the benefit of the
page cache2 and Linux because the cache
is like the files if you don't have it
then we're going to have to go ask a
remote service to fetch it but that
doesn't really happen that often because
we can cache these things like very
efficiently so we get pretty good uh
cash efficient so this drives down the
latency
but if we we fetch it then we store it
on the local SSD so it's cash for the
next time
Okay so
we talked about running images as it
wrote running containers
um running containers so so we have new
now like a way basically to take code
put in a container in the cloud and like
run it on a low you know remote Cloud
computer
but all this file system stuff means we
need to pre-compute a lot of stuff like
for every container image we now have to
um pre-build this index we need to build
this index and store it somewhere so
that when we launched around C we uh we
we know we have this in advance and the
Very janky version is you know so we
stopped using Docker for running
containers
but first version we're still going to
use Docker for building containers
and so the slow bad way to do it is
you want to build this index like of
like Edward fascism so we still use
Docker for building the image and then
we take the container we take the
container image we export it to disk we
compute checksums of every single file
on that on that um in that directory
uh which is you know it could be like 30
000 files or 100 000 or whatever and
then we store that index on NFS too
and this turns out to be kind of
annoying too
people don't need to build images that
often but it's still like this is way
too slow it takes like several minutes
and it's you know let's say you want to
just install a python package I find it
kind of annoying if it takes a minute
and so
what is building an image
building a container image
is if you think about it essentially
just running a container and then
running a command like the Cornerstone
of Dockers like the Run Command right
there's a bunch of other commands too
but if you're running a uh if you're
building an image essentially what
should happen is you're running an
arbitrary shell command in a container
and then the result of that container
you snapshot that back to New Image
uh so our the idea here is basically
indoctor does the same thing with we use
overlayfs so we start a container then
we use overlay FS which is this like
temporary like layered file system
we run an arbitrary command inside this
container using the Machinery we already
built using run C and then it writes all
the new data to separate directly using
overlayfs and then we can just look at
all the Delta upload and the files we
haven't seen so far to NFS and then
compute this index the only problem here
is like we now need to implement a
Docker file parser ourselves because
we're throwing out docker but we wanted
to support Docker files because Docker
files are kind of nice like people
understand Docker files and it's sort of
you know well understood sort of indoct
so yeah so like we have to implement but
here's like the you know we did this in
Rust like here's like one you know
there's a big like match statement and
this is the run a branch of this like
it's not that many commands it's the Run
copy EnV there's like a few other ones
work there entry point we basically
support all of them now it's not that
hard but it's kind of annoying
okay
so
I talked about running containers very
fast like we now have the the ability to
start a container in the cloud in about
a second running custom images
and we also put the user code inside of
it
I talked about building containers
building container images very fast
there's a bunch of other stuff we also
need to do
so we also need to maintain a pool of
worker instances in the cloud we need to
scale that up and down
and we need to build a scheduling
mechanism that takes uh work that we
have to do and assigns it to to the
workers in the cloud
so that's sort of what kubernetes does
but we decided to do that ourselves too
and so it's like conceptually I think
it's this one is like
less complex but it's probably encode
more
we basically
instead of like leveraging like existing
tools like we we use the low level like
ec2 apis and so we spawn
workers who spawn instances using ec2
and then we terminate them ourselves and
that way we can actually Auto scale very
quickly launching and easy Tunes is
actually very fast it only takes 40
seconds much slower on the gcp for some
reason
um and then you know we do a little bit
of a trick with like over provisioning
because because modal modal is
multi-tenants we run a lot of different
users code on modal and so we get the
benefit of pooling all that variants
right like the total variance goes down
with like one over a square root of n
the relative variance so the nice thing
is like when you do that you get a much
smoother sort of overall
load
so it's kind of a nice thing to have but
there's still going to be like spikes
like someone comes in and wants to run
like a lot of stuff so we have always a
little bit of margin like in case like
someone needs to scale up very quickly
we have a few like standby instances uh
and then the other thing we need to
think about is driving utilization right
like one of the benefits of
multi-tenancies we can potentially
improve utilization a lot which is a
massive economic incentive for us like
because it lowers our cost of of goods
and we do that primarily by like
monitoring every worker checking the the
CPU GPU and memory and then uh and then
allocating work to workers based on you
know predicted resource utilization and
current resource utilization of those
workers and this basically turns out
into this like function as a service
platform
so so what we realized is like instead
of like users running containers
actually the nice primitive that I think
people want is functions so that's what
model does
sorry I should have like included a
bunch of slides about modal but I didn't
want to like be like an obnoxious vendor
so I didn't do that so that's why I'm
only talking about technology we can go
check it out on the website later
modal.com
so we built basically like a function as
a service platform right on top of this
because we have all this functionality
to start containers very quickly
and so the idea is like in Python you
can write you know a function in Python
and you can put a decorator on it and
then that gives you the ability we can
deploy that to the cloud in about a
second and then you can call that
function and you don't have to think
about scaling it scales up and down it
scales down to zero right so there's a
little bit more work also to support you
know this like function as a service
like besides scaling the overall
resource pool we also have to scale like
for every function like how many workers
does it or how many containers does that
function have
but the nice thing is
particular application where this turns
out to be super useful for its gpus so
gpus are very expensive right so people
who run political inference on GPU they
have like very unpredictable loads and
so you know
they they need the ability so serverless
gpus Financial is a product that makes a
lot of sense for people people don't
want to provision a bunch like a GPU
cluster that just sits idle in case
there's like a peak you know you don't
want a provision for Peak capacity
because that's very expensive because
you have all these GPU instances that
are just sitting you underutilized what
you want to do is you want to Auto scale
up and down as work comes in and you
need to scale very quickly so all this
stuff around like built like booting
containers quickly turns out to be super
useful when you're doing function as a
service in particular for this GPU stuff
GPU has a bunch of other like more
complex stuff
because not just do you need to boot the
containers quickly you also need to like
load potentially very large models like
from that work to disk hopefully it's
already cached then from disk to CPU and
then from CPU to GPU we're talking like
stable Fusion is like five gigabytes so
it's very important to like improve all
these like bottlenecks from cold start
um
what does this let us do yeah I mean
does this work
yeah I think it works
there's a video it's like running modal
but it doesn't work
uh but like yeah I mean like one of the
things that lets us do I'll tell you
this video you can imagine in your head
uh this is basically like builds a
container it builds a container image
uh in a few seconds and then stores it
in our distributed storage
and then right after it launches a
hundred containers with this image
and you know all in like a handful of
like five to ten seconds right so yeah
so so now we're starting to get to this
point we're like
we're almost like better than local
development in the sense that like you
know we can build containers locally you
don't have to think about Docker I don't
know about you I don't I'm not a big fan
of Docker the CLI is very unintuitive to
me
uh and we can build but we can build
arbitrary containers we can launch them
in the cloud and we can scale up and
down very quickly so we have this
ability now to like you can build this
like fan out thing
uh and and and you have this feedback
loop that almost like it feels like
you're writing code locally it actually
executes in the cloud you have the
scalability of the cloud
and I mean it has like one example you
know it's a lot of stable diffusion a
lot of dream Booth like a lot of people
running this kind of stuff some of them
more gimmicky some of them more serious
uh but like a lot of you know so so like
a lot of GPU stuff people are on a Model
it's also a lot of other stuff like
people run like web scraping competition
biotech data Pipelines
there's a lot of the stuff that you can
run a model and sort of nice
was it dumb to build this in-house
I think for most people it would be a
very bad idea to do that
you should use a vendor instead maybe
modal
uh I think in the long run my feeling is
like
kubernetes
is this thing that is good enough for a
lot of stuff
but it's not great for anything and in
particular for data teams I think
kubernetes is pretty annoying to do it
with and so what I've seen is a lot of
companies internally they build a data
platform that's a wrapper on top of
kubernetes
and then the wrapper ends up being kind
of leaky
because you know it doesn't handle all
the cases and then people have to learn
kubernetes anyway
and so my feeling is like
you can't like stole these like big
problems by just like putting wrappers
on top of wrappers on top of wrappers
right
you know we wanted like full stack
Engineers but the stack is full there's
like too much stuff in the stack like
you can't fit more stuff in the stock so
anyway so and then you know and should
we have used it like darker's too slow
that's we don't want to use Docker in
kubernetes I think you know maybe you
could have gone I don't know you could
use Lambda maybe but like Lambda is
pretty expensive they don't support gpus
you know so so for us it was the right
thing to do and and to go down in this
you know it was also fun but that's like
me rationalizing maybe like the other
stuff but
um and that's it thank you
[Music]